let's go next to our caller from the
eight for seven area code we're taking
calls at six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty and our next callers
from eight four seven go ahead hi David
hey who's this booth of Steve Steve go
ahead Vermont Illinois okay my question
is do you think over the rest of your
life you will have more influence over
people as a professor teaching focus
classes of 30 or so people at a time or
do you think that your independent media
presence will outstrip any work you
could do as a standard teacher I think
that the scale of the media endeavor is
going to make it significantly more
impactful than the college teaching now
you could make the case that by spending
a semester in a room with 30 students
that you can in pack them to a greater
degree than what it might be if someone
sees a youtube clip or listens to a
podcast or hears me on the radio for 10
minutes but the sheer scale of it 30
students a semester you know where we
estimate our daily audience our daily
unique audience at many hundreds of
thousands of people even at a greater
degree of impact the show is definitely
going to have more of an impact I
believe them to teaching okay yeah it's
just so experienced that in the u.s. it
seems like less and less people care
what educated people you know educators
and intellectuals have to say in our
society even though they're the ones who
are more likely to have a deep
understanding of things yeah but new
media you can actually influence people
so yeah all right well glad I was able
to answer that question for you Steve
very much appreciate the phone call